OPERATIONS IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>>> UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO PAID A PERSONAL
VISIT TO THIS TERRITORY THAT WAS
JUST RECAPTURED FROM RUSSIAN
FORCES.
THIS IS VIDEO HERE SHOWING
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY MEETING WITH
UKRAINIAN TROOPS, SHAKING THEIR
HANDS.
THIS IS IN THE NEWLY LIBERATED
CITY OF IZYUM.
FORCES ENTERED THE CITY JUST
FIVE DAYS AGO AND UKRAINE SAID
TROOPS HAVE TAKEN BACK MORE THAN
3,000 SQUARE MILES OF LAND SINCE
THE START OF THE MONTH.
THOSE, OF COURSE, ARE UKRAINIAN
NUMBERS.
THE PENTAGON SAID IT HAS SEEN A
NUMBER OF RUSSIAN FORCES
CROSSING BACK ACROSS THE BORDER
INTO RUSSIA.
JOINING US TO TALK ABOUT THIS IS
CNN NATIONAL SECURITY ANALYST
BETH SANER, A FORMER OFFICIAL AT
THE OFFICE OF THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IZYUM HERE
WHERE WE SEE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
AND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS TO
THE REGION AS WELL AS THIS CITY
HERE WHICH THEY HAVE RETAKEN.
>> THESE ARE HUGE IN A COUPLE OF
WAYS.
FIRST IT'S JUST MILITARILY,
THESE ARE LOGISTIC HUBS, THE
PLACES WHERE THE SUPPLY LINES
ARE CENTERED FOR RUSSIA.
AND WHERE THEY ABANDONED A LOT
OF EQUIPMENT AS THE MEN FLED.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
IMPORTANT NOT JUST FOR THIS
REGION BUT ALSO AS UKRAINE IS
TRYING TO PUSH SOUTH AND INTO
DONBAS AND EXTEND THIS INTO THE
EASTERN AREA.
SO THESE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
THE OTHER PART OF IT I THINK IS
JUST PSYCHOLOGICALLY.
JUST SEEING ZELENSKYY IN IZYUM
AND RAISING THIS FLAG.
ITS A IMPORTANT FOR THE
UKRAINIANS, IMPORTANT FOR THE
WEST BECAUSE IT SHOWS WHAT WE'RE
GIVING THEM IS WORKING AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IN
RUSSIA IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO DENY
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> HE MAKES A SHOW OF GOING.
HE KNOWS THAT.
>> HE'S GOOD AT THIS.
>> FOR THE PSYCHOLOGICAL PART OF
THIS.
THE OFFENSIVE NOW HAS SLOWED,
WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE, BUT
PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE THERE IS
THIS FOCUS ON LEEMAN.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> IN TERMS OF WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE, LOOKING MORE AT THE
DONBAS --
>> IN THE EAST.
>> -- IN THE EAST.
AND THERE'S ALSO A RUSSIAN, YOU
KNOW, WORKING HERE.
THERE'S A LOT OF FIGHTING GOING
ON THERE.
SO THEY'RE, OF COURSE, GOING TO
BE SLOWING BECAUSE AFTER SIX
DAYS OF FIGHTING, THE UKRAINIAN
FORCES ARE TIRED AND THEY HAVE
TO REGROUP THEMSELVES.
SO WE SHOULD EXPECT, A UKRAINIAN
DEFENSE MINISTER CAME OUT TODAY
AND SAUD WE SHOULD EXPECT THINGS
TO BE A LITTLE BIT SLOWER BUT
THIS IS A KEY FOCUS HERE BECAUSE
IT'S THE GATEWAY TO THE DONBAS.
>> TO THE LUHANSK REGION.
>> YES.
>> AND PUTIN SAID THEY WERE
GOING TO TAKE LUHANSK AND
DONETSK.
AND WITH DEPLETION OF FORCES
MOST EXPERTS SAY THE RUSSIANS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THIS TERRITORY HERE IN THE
STRIPES.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR AIMS IN TAKING THE
DONBAS.
IN FACT, PROBABLY LOSE GROUND.
>> THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN WHAT HE HAS LOST
IN THE KHARKIV REGION.
WHAT WORRIES DO YOU HAVE ABOUT
HOW HE MIGHT REACT HERE?
>> WE ARE SEEING IN MOSCOW, YOU
KNOW, TRYING TO SHIFT THE
NARRATIVE.
THEY HAVE HAD TO ADMIT THIS, BUT
IT'S NOT PUTIN'S FAULT, RIGHT.
IT'S SOMEBODY ELSE'S FAULT.
IT'S THE MILITARY'S FAULT, BAD
INTELLIGENCE, THOSE THINGS ARE
TRUE, BUT PUTIN ALSO HAS BEEN IN
CHARGE OF THIS WAR AND TAKEN
COMMAND.
HE'S MAKING COMMAND DECISIONS
BUT HE'S DISTANCING HIMSELF.
SO NOW WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS
A LOT OF THE DISCUSSION PICKING
UP IN SOCIAL MEDIA IS ABOUT
CARPET BOMBING UKRAINIAN CITIES,
ABOUT REALLY TAKING IT OUT ON
THE CIVILIANS IN UKRAINE.
FOR A WHILE THE KREMLIN WAS
PULLING BACK FROM THAT AND NOW
WE'RE SEEING THEM PICK UP ON
STATE TV THIS MANTRA.
I AM EXPECTING THAT THE RUSSIANS
ARE GOING TO TRY TO CHANGE
SOMEHOW THE TENOR OF THE WAR AND
THEY CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE MEN ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
SO WHAT'S LEFT